hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action unleashes where I will be
playing some rapid games in order to try
and provide the useful commentary for
some of the players that are just
getting into chess and sometimes it
takes me a bit more time to to explain
my thought process and then I will uh
maybe struggle with with time trouble uh
but the point of these games is not to
win every game or to play as best as
possible it's to try and explain the
thought process behind the moves that I
make so sometimes okay I will run into
the time travel mostly uh but I feel
like uh it will be more useful for
others this way uh but I will I will try
to do the commentary during my
opponent's thinking time if at all
possible okay this is time for bullet
Let's uh increase this to 10 minutes per
player and as usual we are only
accepting higher rated opponents um so
let's see who we get this
game uh yeah last time it took quite a
while to to find an opponent maybe no
one is playing playing at this time it's
currently
12:45 uh p.m. uh Central European Time
and our opponent is p Pro from Greece
rated 2296 and we are continuing with E4
uh depending on what our opponent plays
yeah we will
be uh facing the Sicilian Defense so
we've also been playing the Sicilian
Defense but we went for the hyper
accelerated Dragon he goes for the
standard D6 stuff which most of the
times means that it's going to be a
knorf so yeah Knight F6 Knight to C3 a
six and we're going to continue with the
Adams attack with Pawn to H3 and the
idea is G4 G5 sometimes they stop this
with the immediate H5 which is fine but
basically you want to you want to
develop your light Square Bishop to this
diagonal maybe put the bishop on on E3
and um okay sometimes it could be a
little bit tricky because you do give up
the C4 Square uh and uh you know if you
decide to go this way then the you know
putting a knight on C4 might be might be
very useful
uh but yeah B5 okay not super familiar
with that but uh obviously he wants to
get um the the bishop to to B7 to put
pressure on this pawn and also if I just
go G5 now uh he might play Bishop to uh
B7 which will again put more uh more
pressure on my E4 Pawn so I'm not sure
what to make of this or if it's even
good
uh but it is interesting
yeah it is interesting I I I don't know
how to how to tackle this uh so I'm
going to have to abandon my plan for the
moment for the moment we are abandoning
our plan we're going to play Queen to E2
and now we're going to go for the
advancement of the
pawn uh sorry it took uh took me like a
minute to to figure this
out and it might not even be the best of
plans but it is is uh it is what I have
and that's what I meant by sort of
explaining my thought process here as
you know if I just continued with my
plan my opponent would play B4 wi the E4
pawn and I would be in a pretty bad spot
here so yeah he knows what I'm doing he
wants to go for this uh uh Knight
maneuver to C4 or he might even put it
to E5 we'll see what it does but we are
continuing with G4 we want to play G5
the uh make this Knight sort of feel
weird about being placed there so I'm
imagining uh C6
here uh maybe not allowing G5 but no he
he wants to put more pressure here first
okay so we're going to defend Bishop G2
we are defending it three times he's
attacking it three times and we're
having we're having a good time
threatening
G5 uh but he is
persistent okay so E5 is always a great
move uh he does give me the F5 square
and and he will have sort of a permanent
weakness on D6 so now I will play a
bishop E3 castles Queen side and I will
put more pressure here if he plays G6 to
get rid of my knight then okay he gets
rid of my knight but he does uh push
more Pawns in front of his King and uh
yeah I do get to REM maneuver my knight
I don't get to REM maneuver it via the
E3 Square because then I uh weaken my
Pawn again so I will have to play it to
G3 uh but okay from there it will also
be guarding the the pawn here
uh should be very nice and he has to
calculate is it okay to capture on e4
and no it's not he's going to just go
back we're going to go to
G3 uh I actually didn't calculate if it
was okay for him to capture here I just
thought no way it can be uh as it's okay
now it's defended four times previously
was defended three times so it's a bit
of a nimzovich way to go about things
you know overprotecting uh one of your
one of your uh strong points and then
just piling up on your opponent's
weakness which is the D6 pawn and that
will be sort of our game plan here okay
so he wants to take advantage of D4 and
F4 now being weakened and uh I have to
decide in this particular setup do I
want to go Queen side or do do I want to
go King
side so maybe maybe going uh
H this is very
interesting
yeah this is very
interesting yeah I will play Bishop to
E3 to keep my options
open and if he goes to F4 I might even
capture it not really sure
yet it because there might be some
Knight F4 Bishop captures Pawn captures
and I play Knight F5 back to sort of
sacrifice my
knight um as this would open up uh the
the attack towards his King and also
open up this diagonal uh but yeah he
stops uh sort of wants to stop Knight to
C Knight to
D5 but yeah I think now we can Castle
King side
safely yeah we Castle King site
safely
yeah he's uh also not not interested in
making a decision uh he he he's keeping
his King in the center of the board you
know leaving all of his options
open and uh well we don't have much we
either we either sacrifice on F5 if you
know the position calls for it uh or we
double up on the on the D file put
pressure on the black's weakness which
is the D6 pawn and uh yeah we don't have
to worry about any pushes here the C2
Pawn PA also is defended so as you can
see he is spending more time than me
which is very rare obviously means that
there are some merits to my position so
he just goes Bishop to E7 he wants to
Castle and um yeah now it's time to
decide do we go for the D file and uh
focus our attention on the D6 Pawn or do
we go for something like King to H2
followed by F4 and we go for an attack
against the black king I think both
could have uh some it uh also Bishop to
H6 might not be something to throw away
but then I lose control over the D4
square and uh might be might be sort of
a
problem yeah we're we're going for
this we're going for
this and also it's useful if we ever
decide to go for Knight to F5 uh and
let's say a trade happens he he goes g
captures I play e captures this would
open up this possibility which if he
captures he might still be attacking my
Rook on F1 so being The Rook being on D1
uh might be very useful here but yeah
we're basically just slow playing it uh
controlling B4 which is one of Black's
ideas always controlling D5 which is
also Black's idea always and now we're
just going to uh double up on the D file
and we we'll take it from there probably
maybe even include the other plan that
we discussed putting the King on H2 uh
maybe going for F4 uh in the future
maybe even F5 so we'll
see uh it's always weird you know when
your opponent is spending time you you
could think okay he's now struggling
trying to find a move because it's also
not easy for me to figure out what black
would play here and there are so many
options that it's hard to even theorize
uh you know you always have to watch out
for something like Rook captures and C3
as it's a standard sacrifice in the
Sicilian Defense luckily for me the E4
Pawn is now defended by both the bishop
and the the Knight so he cannot go for
the standard Rook captur Knight captur
idea and now he wants to yeah he wants
to stop my expansion on the king side
and he wants to provoke
G5 but okay I I actually think this is
good for me so I'm just going to play
it yeah he goes here he he shifts his
attention to the to the C5 Square now we
have to play
H4
and now sort of castling King side
should be safe for him because of uh
because of a blocked position but I
don't know I'm not really
sure not really sure about
that cuz if he castles then Knight to F5
might even be a very very unpleasant
option for
him yeah and it's um you can always have
the watch out for those like uh
sacrificing the Knight on D5 and the E5
In the
Sicilian against the Sicilian uh yeah so
he does it so okay do do we have a way
to improve because we don't have to rush
this by any by any means so we we could
even play Rook to D2 and get this Rook
into the game first uh because I don't
think there's a way for him to force
anything here and we could also play
Knight captures on H5 G uh like Knight
captures and H5 G captures Queen
captures uh but what is the continuation
here that is the that is the real
question so there's
that I mean it also doesn't look bad but
he he has no ways of stopping that so we
don't have to rush
it yeah the Knight coming to D4 or F4 is
nice but even if he does that then we
can sacrifice so I'm guessing we just
double up
here we just double up here and all of
the tactics that uh you know exist will
exist even after the doubling up but it
at least we should improve our position
as much as possible uh before committing
the the such ideas but yeah I'm sort of
liking Knight captures on H5 even more
than Knight to F5 Knight to F5 is not
even a sacrifice as you know once once
he captures uh the Knight will be
hanging and also okay so he does go for
that he sort of forces our hand into
going for this Knight captures on H5 we
will do it and we do have this sare
under control so yeah nothing to worry
about there the Knight coming to D5 also
could be very dangerous for
him
yeah yeah it will be very interesting to
see what what he
does yeah the Knight is coming here
that's sort of
uh sort of necessary and he does now
gain control over
F3 uh and he does stop Pawn to G G6 but
we're not interested in Pawn to G6 right
away H so let's
uh yeah I kind of want to play Knight to
D5 but then after we trade this weakens
my C2 Pawn as I don't think there's
anything he can do
here like I don't think there's even a
good move for him here uh we can just go
for Bishop H3 also as it comes with
tempo but we're not really interested in
capturing The Rook uh we're mostly
interested in
uh we're mostly interested in this
bishop to F5 move going for
checkmate so he could stop that with
something like F5 but I really don't
believe that's that's even a
move I mean if anything he just gives
back material but we're going to capture
alasan and then everything will be
hanging this bishop is pretty bad here
um
yeah I don't know Bishop Bishop F5 looks
to be very strong so he does go for Rook
captures on C3 uh and of course the idea
is that once we capture he will capture
here and he will have the H7 Square
guarded but uh we don't have to react to
that we can just play Bishop F5 and uh
sort
of sort of force him to play what Knight
G6 okay but he can play I'm going to
capture he's going to capture I'm going
to capture and then I pick up the Rook
here while guarding the pawn and we've
won our material back and um sort of
ended the game on the spot but no okay
very interesting if if we play this he
also has Knight to F3
check but that's nothing yeah that's
nothing for us to worry about so yeah
Bishop
here and now a sort of Knight to G6 does
appear to be the only move he has
because if he moves the road then just
checking here and this is
Checkmate um so he will have to play
this but then it's then it's game
over yeah I don't think there's
a uh I don't think there's a better way
of playing
this yeah he he's probably trying to
figure out if Knight to F3 check is
anything at all here but it's
not since after King H1 there's no
there's no move here oh there is okay
there is maybe yeah kn3 check King H1 he
can capture on G5 but no that's just
silly yeah we go here I don't see the
point of of Knight to
F3 huh perhaps he will explain it to
me yeah but now Knight G5 I just capture
H captures on G5 five it's
nothing yeah or I'm missing
stuff uh but yeah I kind of think maybe
Knight to G6 I think both ideas are lost
for black but I think Knight to G6 was
perhaps a bit more
resilient yeah F6 is nothing we just
deliver a mate in
one yeah which is uh I mean it's
interesting that uh uh last last video I
made was on Michael Adams and this uh
this game I'm playing the the Adams
attack against the Sicilian so you know
it's it's nice when things work
out regardless of the outcome of the
game of course I might still lose this
as sometimes sometimes I miss the
weirdest stuff and you know I think I'm
completely winning and then my opponent
just says Nope your position is actually
terrible so now he controls the H7
Square we do have to recapture here uh
but the that that's still
nothing yeah he doesn't have any checks
uh I mean he he can do one or maybe this
one well maybe maybe bishop captures
with check Bishop captures and F5 yeah
that's sort of a move but
still yeah you can do that
sure so is there what's the cleanest way
to end this what's the cleanest
way play
G6 thre and mate play G6 Rook F7 and
then we pin The Rook pin the rook and
that's pretty much
it do we do something else like we could
also give a check first and then mate on
H6 that's also
possible okay this looks cooler but you
know it's it's better to play correct
moves than than the cool
ones sometimes I go for the cool move
instead of the correct one and then I
miss my opponent's cool move and then he
really really punishes me so yeah it's
better to do it this way all right good
game Mr Perry Pro 100 uh now it's time
for the fun part let's analyze all of
the things we've done
poorly so uh we've had it a few times on
this rapid series I went for the Adams
attack and he played B5 yeah okay I
thought A4 was the way to go uh but I
wasn't sure uh but okay let's let's see
now so that we remember it for Forever
Knight D5 and of course captur runs into
Bishop to C4 which seems to be very good
for white but yeah it's hard to commit
for something like this if you don't
know that it's uh uh it's very good for
sure and then what Bishop B7 you go for
the oh it's sort sort of you go for the
for the immediate uh destruction you
know you wake up and you choose a
violence Bishop G5 wow Knight C6 and now
we capture and after Bishop captures
King head castles so basically just a
really really strong way of uh getting a
lot of of initiative and after this you
will pick up the B4 Pawn Yeah okay G6
what this is a this line lasts forever
and now you Capt on A6 and you're you
have the past a and pass B pawns and
completely being completely winning so
the early B5 should be met with A4 and
seems to be very hard for black to play
I played A3 Bishop B7 and I played Queen
E2 okay Knight here
G4 uh my opponent went for Knight C5 uh
really going for that E4 Pawn uh Knight
F5 G6 uh Knight to G3 okay so this is
all pretty standard stuff castles Bishop
to E7 Rook D1 I decided to go for for
the doubling up of the pawns and he went
H5 G5 we go here yeah it's still pretty
much z0 territory yeah see the engine is
giving Knight F5 as we've discussed here
uh and while I do enjoy it uh I decided
to go for Rook to D2 first uh which uh
for some reason the engine doesn't like
for me yeah the engine doesn't like My
Sacrifice at all uh because of what yeah
Rook captures on E3 right away but why
is it good now that's the question why
is Rook captures on E3 good now B
captures Knight E5 okay sort of stops
the attack ah okay so he wanted to do it
this way uh to to guard the G6 square
and now if I try my idea of Bishop to H3
yeah now of course Bishop captures an
four now it's impossible so this is how
he he could have defended against it
yeah uh but I played the he played
Knight to E5 right away and then Bishop
to H3 is very strong so it's basically
the only move that allows me to take
advantage of his um weird idea but still
F5 is the way to go and then G6 King G7
Queen H7 with check he the engine says
that it is possible to defend this but
he went for Rook capts on C3 now uh the
move that he should have gone for few
moves ago but now uh after this it's
completely winning so yeah if he went
for Knight to G6 the move we discussed
uh it's still not very good for him
Queen H6 check King G8 and now G6 Rook
F7 captures captures and now we deliver
a check and also pick up the The Rook
here and now we're going to have two
Rooks against two Bishops and of course
he's going to be completely winning he
didn't go for that he allowed the
Checkmate to appear on the board and
after Bishop captures yeah there's not
much here that he can do we played one
check and he resigned here yeah uh like
I said uh if we went for G6 uh it's
still completely winning but yeah this
is m m in a few moves
so uh of course it's always better to go
for that Queen H6 Checkmate
yeah uh not the not the most precise
game of the Adam attack against the
Sicilian I did give my opponent that one
chance for Rook captures on C3 I didn't
see it uh but luckily for me neither did
he but you know it's always important to
know about this option because black
will always sacrifice that Rook on C3
and uh to to tell you the truth I hate
playing against it with white because it
gives black so much counterplay whenever
black plays again plays it against me I
always uh you know I kind of wish I was
the one playing with the black pieces
it's also one of the reasons why I want
to become a sicilian player because it's
just so wonderful to sacrifice The
Exchange like this but we'll see uh so
far I'm I'm doing okay but with very
very mixed results uh so yeah once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon checking up on your
wonderful suggestions continuing the
London chess classic and continuing this
rapid series hoping to improve and hope
you guys are improving uh with me as
well uh so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day